[Music]
i've been asked
before
for simple helpful
exercises
that make it
easy and relatable
to embody oneness to embody unity
to embody more and more of the true
essence of
the nature of reality
and so i'm going to give you a pretty
simple one
take the different environments
that you're at
for example here
you see that we're at a beautiful
beach in this case it's laguna beach
but if you don't have access to a place
in nature
like this you can leverage something
as simple as people watching at a local
mall let's say
and so the exercise
is while you people watch
at the beach or at the mall
is can you
look through all points of view
simultaneously
so what i'm asking you to do
is to hold
all of the points of view that are
happening
of god of the creator
simultaneously of the one
so another way to look at that
is to
begin doing things like
[Music]
slowly blurring
the line which is completely artificial
the boundary the wall
between different people
and where these people end
and where another person begins
and so what you're doing is you're
taking the
point of view
from here
and you're taking the point of view
from here from here from here
and what you're doing is you're
combining all of the points of view
into one homogeneous unity substrate
okay combine all of the points of view
into one homogeneous unity substrate
so blur the line dissolve
more and more of the boundary the wall
between all of the points of view
in this practice whether you're at the
mall or at the beach
what's gonna happen is you're gonna
notice that this
this unity substrate
of all combined the points of view
it's like a it's like a diamond fractal
it's a diamond because it's
indescribably
perfect exactly as it is
all of the different points of view and
their unique
expression their unique journey
their unique individuation in creation
and it's a fractal because everyone's
point of view
is self-similar
it's
a pattern that repeats
and so you're taking all of these points
of view
at the beach
all of these points of view
and what you're doing is you're
combining them all you're merging them
all you're dissolving the wall
the artificial boundary of separation
between the points of view
and you're merging all of those
beautiful points of view
into the view the one
the infinite creator god
and you're holding that view you're
holding
the view
this is a very simple practice
to be able to tap in
to what was taught by the greatest sages
and the greatest mystic traditions
and even science is johnny come lately
coming to the same conclusion
embody this practice and you will more
clearly more
vividly be able to feel the
unconditional love radiating from your
heart
because you have merged all
of what appeared to be distinct
points of view as separate entities into
one homogeneous conscious
substrate of god of the creator itself
the diamond fractal itself
do this practice more and more often and
feel that unconditional
love unity oneness
that permeates everything and yet we
perpetually
overlook this is
the root
and if we do this right
this is the most
upstream solution to catalyze the most
downstream harmony and flourishing
as a collective